das sind goldbarren junge ne meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir denken
mit schrecken haben das ereignis vor
einigen tagen zurück seinen des juristin
hamburg rumgelaufen und da hat an der
alster dinge im bus versteckt und dann
so getan als hätte sie gefunden weißt du
ich glaube es ein treffen mit der waffe
gesagt nichts dann hab ich darüber ein
video gemacht wir haben zusammen gelacht
wir haben zusammen kritisch darüber
nachgedacht
natürlich hat jetzt nicht aber wir haben
darüber nachgedacht was an diesem tag
passiert dann hatten wir eigentlich gut
sondern ist die sache abgehakt
nicht ganz denn der blick in youtube
trends zeigt dass platz eins schon
wieder von einem fluss gefundenen dingen
in diesem fall des wissenschafts
scheinbar belegte diesmal so groß da
sagen wir schon rein okay leute der
erste blick auf spam mail zeigt wir sind
über zehn minuten das aber nichts da das
ganz normal heutzutage und wir haben da
eine schatzkiste scheinbar das muss ja
nicht sein eigentlich ja der leute der
blick auf die displays spricht eine
sprache die sehr ungewiss für die frank
rost 18.000 likes zu 11.000 discs und
das bei 1,6 millionen abonnenten also
das sollte endlich der eigenen community
wenn es ein gutes video ist mehr
dahinter stehenden verteidigen er ist
hier schon mal nicht passiert ist nicht
nur noch mehr gespannt
wie sollte was gelernt war aber dass
calvin und leute wir folgen der spur
2000 zwar müssen wir zur brücke werden
der letzte mal bei der schatzsuche
diesen kleinen nicht stattgefunden
und da schon der hinweis dass wir boote
sollen ich muss ehrlich gestehen der
stelle leute ich weiß nicht ganz genau
worüber sie reden aber ich glaube die
haben vermutlich mal das ist meine
deutung der ganzen sache irgendwo irgend
einen hinweis auf den schatz gefunden
und gehen diesem hinweis jetzt erstmal
die erste brücke
sagen wir ich muss sagen heute an der
stelle ich finde es sehr gut dass unsere
beiden indiana jones ist hier gut
ausgestattet sind mit der richtigen
ausrüstung um den schatz zu bergen und
auch eventuell etwas ältere wertvolle
gegenstände zu konservieren nämlich mit
versace und taschen richtig geile samt
wegkicken früher
wer kennt es nicht die bastei lehmann
geil sandberg in konnte erst mal gucken
was jetzt
dieser effekt ist was relevant ist was
drin
er weiß ich schon klar rot ja kann man
glaube ich schon sagen noch getroffen
leute noch getroffen dass es dabei
eigentlich nicht aber theoretisch gibt
es auch schon das was ihr nicht gefällt
ist
ich denke ich etwas gewollt
ich glaube jetzt wird's jetzt wird es
ein bisschen kritik
es ist ein fakt ist die erste rein
gelegt schwierig ist es für alte leute
es geht jetzt alter leinwand schaffte
ganz kurz ein blick in die kommentare
geil der kommentar von hendrik zweifel
neuer trend auf youtube dinge die man
voraus in den fluss wirkt wieder
rauszuholen so tun als hätte man
alzheimer und hat diesen gegenstand noch
nie gesehen alter den nagel auf den kopf
getroffen
die gut seitlich grad echten schaffte
man muss sagen so weit sieht das einfach
krank verkauf so acting level ist auf
jeden fall 0 von 100 in diesem moment
also realistisch gesehen so eine halbe
stunde bitte also ich bin so gespannt
was jetzt angefragt haben ich bin so
gespannt
das wird locker richtig kalt wird
[Musik]
wie gesagt junge schon einmal als gold
saß das sind goldbarren junge gold war
dann erst ganz kurz überlegt dass wir
sollten so zwei goldbarren sein oder
einen goldbarren also sagen wir so grob
ein kilo kostet 33 1406 euro also haben
wir hier ungefähr 66.000 euro in dieser
kiste drin ist natürlich echt also wenn
das nicht recht ist weiß ich auch nicht
weiter dass das sind goldbarren junge
[Musik]
das ist geil sind schon schatz seiner
das passt so überhaupt nicht rein ohne
wenn es dann nicht anderem sieht daran
sieht man dass die post das selbst
gemacht haben ich glaube nur die project
fonds würden in eine schatztruhe
irgendwas von louie vito reinmachen
möglichkeit louie vito in der
schatztruhe ein gutschein von 1000 euro
nein sie sind als 23 10 13 stück also
haben wir quasi 13 50 650 euro dahin
geldscheinen das ist natürlich auf jeden
fall interessanter als 66.000 euro in
gold also ich will mir erst mal genau
die ganze anschauen
das nicht mehr und das kostet alles klar
auch hier gut dann spürbar zurück und
haben es noch mal an wie sun gehört wenn
zwei echte goldbarren jeweils ein kino
in den sakralen das klingt nämlich dann
lustigerweise bisschen wie plastik
[Musik]
stabil
da muss man dazu noch sagen erst recht
ist hier schon eine halbe stunde auf
heute was soll man dazu sagen platz eins
mit so einer pause weiter ich wollte sie
auch so als ob man kann keine hollywood
filmen oder so was ich mache mir nichts
vor aber was soll ist das ist aber so
offensichtlich fake das kommt den trend
platz eins da muss man auf jeden fall
los das war soweit der große gefundenen
schatz von denen indiana jones groß wenn
ihr jetzt ein video sehen wollt was
nicht vergisst und auch nicht auf fake
videos reagiert dann könnte ich hier
eine folge von was es geht von meinem
format und julia checken einfach
bisschen was anderes als trends platz
eins mit einer selbst in den bach
geworfen kiste perfekt machte